inside of Peru's Congress legislators
shouted assassin at Prime Minister
Alberto tarola as he entered the chamber
to ask for a vote of confidence
we declare that the government remains
solidly focused on its political action
plan to pacify the country we are not an
authoritarian regime nor do we oppose
legitimate protests but we have as a
state the obligation to safeguard the
security of the majority of peruvians
democracy would be defended at any price
triggering anger among some opposition
legislators
these constant threats from Mr otterolla
are shameful saying that what they've
done is right that is that they
recognize they're the authors of the
massacres that the Peruvian people have
suffered in these days but that they
will continue to do the same
the government imposed a three-day
curfew in the southern region of puno
after at least 18 people including a
policeman were killed in clashes when
demonstrators tried to take over the
airport
otarole has offered help to the families
of the victims as part of a strategy to
pacify the country but protesters are
not satisfied with any of the
government's attempts to quilt the
unrest
prime minister otarolas is the
government wants to build Bridges with
protesting groups they've sent
high-level commissions to several areas
in the country but he says people are
not willing to sit down for dialogue
instead in the aftermath of the
deadliest day of protests in a
month-long crisis shattered families are
left to mourn their loved ones
my son is dead I am his father he was 16
years old
foreign
the U.N High Commissioner for human
rights is urging Peru's government to
carry out a prompt and impartial
investigation into the deaths of
protesters and to hold those responsible
to account
while many peruvians want the violence
and destruction to stop others say the
political crisis will only end with
President dinabaluarte's resignation
Mariana sanchezida Lima